uh okay so let's go through first of all
talk about the name of your project they
call you the big dude
so there's have you ever watched The Big
Lebowski yeah the dude yeah he's right
there that's the dude as well it's my
favorite movie ever well I remember that
so why are you the big dude
um I call myself a big dude because like
I can't anything come my way
and God don't play about me so that's
the meaning of no big dude to be honest
and to be a dude you got to be a dude
you got to be a dude you got to know how
to have a little fun right
[__] right yeah for sure yeah what
part of Memphis you're from Frasier
shout out to Frasier boy we have Frasier
Frasier Legend I remember I bought his
album when I was probably like 11 years
old which dates me well you right now
35.
how old are you 26. well you ain't that
yeah you ain't the youngest of pups
you've lived enough life I'm a young OG
yeah for sure for sure man uh how long
you been rapping man
um
life five years now so not too long so
you started rapping me about 20 21. yeah
that's a that's kind of late night
what like gravitated you towards
starting that [__]
um
I was a drum major at first so I really
want to rap it first the girl major so
you were like Drumline type [__] no like
I was the person that was like got the
feeling on top of the head like leading
the band but you were in the band yeah
nice I was I was the head head captain
though oh so you were like you were like
the leader I was the one that was
winning all the battle of the bands and
so you were a musical already yeah so
you could get down with some drumsticks
yeah for sure yeah if you should not
snares though huh bass drone the bass
drums okay so you that's obviously kind
of a pretty natural transition because
you're already into music so was there
something where it was just like
what's the career in being the drum guy
nah I just um
I always wanted to be somebody big but I
didn't know yeah yeah the big dude
I was I always want to be somebody big
but I didn't know who I was gonna be
though I'm saying but I knew I was gonna
be big someday
it is but I'm saying like to start
rapping at 21. that's a pretty serious I
mean like you obviously were you good
right away
I mean I was at Rhythm you always say I
mean you got to have rhythm yeah you
gotta have rhythm
um I just didn't I just didn't have
nothing to talk about but I had a lot to
talk about right you know what I'm
saying so like I didn't have a lot to
talk about like stunt wise or but I had
a story though right I'm saying so
I ain't rich but I ain't worse my
process where'd you go to college
I didn't go to college but um I turned
it down oh yeah I turned it down just to
do this just the ground from the rap so
you uh had an opportunity to do the drug
thing scholarship and everything rap
um I think it was like in Jacksonville
yeah a big a big band in Jacksonville
it's a big college though and they
offered me like
fitting some [__] like 10 million or
something like that five million
something like that
scholarship
okay but not five million dollars
55 million dollars yeah
what the [__] are we doing here like
word for y'all like that's what I'm
saying but I was so younger like wait
wait wait I didn't know what it was are
you sure they average you five million
dollars
it was a scholarship like I had to go to
school for this decade
but you would get 5 million yeah it was
somewhere it was in the millions though
listen man
it obviously worked out because you have
a gigantic
Pitbull yeah that's got how much was
that 130 130 it it's all worked out
honestly my little brother
is he did he pass away yeah oh man rest
in peace
that's a crazy chain yeah uh how long
ago did your brother pass uh two years
ago two years yeah something like that
that's a big loss yeah look my baby
brother especially being your baby
brother you feel like you have a protect
the machine you know is that something
that like you feel like kind of changed
your life
a lot
each time my attitude maybe your
mentality towards things
yeah it really known me to a lot so a
lot of [__] don't get to me
that's true you go through some crazy
[__] it almost like
enormous
people yeah no I've been there I've been
I've been through some like wild ass
relationships in my life where I'm like
man I Miser right that [__] like this
this [__] ain't nothing
yes you know for sure I just get high
about it I just chill on me I won't be
bothered right right yeah was uh was he
a part a part of the music [__] with you
or yeah he was he was here where I was
just my baby brother you know what I'm
saying like
yeah that's terrible man I'm sorry for
your loss bro for sure